Tâm thông nghĩ đơn đơn chám là chính thức công bố trình trình thịt thực mới, gọi là thể văn,
đuất kế để thủng sòng bố lớn từ dựa tương phased sân nghiệp.
Thậu quyết định các nhân gí một chựa đô lắm ý, sẽ đo thức quyền từ chủ tại Mỹ,
tòn xuất nghiệp muốn bảo lãnh nhân viên sẽ phải trả hai chựa đô lắm ý trong bố trường hợp.
Ngoài ra Washington dự kiến trịn khai thải mặt kiên với giải năm chựa đô lắm ý,
cho phép người dở đình Mỹ tổ ra hai chăm bệm ngày 1 năm,
mà không phải được thời đối với tôi như phát sân ngoài lãnh thổ.
Công ngày tầm thống trọng cũng kiết sắp lãnh áp dụng khoảng vĩ thương nghiệp một chăm nghiệp đô lắm ý,
bởi thịt thực hạt một bệm, dành cho là đậu ký năng cao.
Quý định này kiến như tập đoàn công nghệ lòng ngày gí vị tưởng dụng cuối tầy tăng mạng.
Đồng thời cũng có người cơ tà đọng đến tị trưởng ở đậu trúng lắm.
Chính xác mới phà lãnh ưu tiền của chính quyền Mỹ cho việc sép chả cáo đậu đồng lương hoài.
Đồng thời cũng đại trong hút vấn lợt tưu trịt.